[Music]
your recent book the evolution of
everything seems to have a democratic
and anti-elitist approach to
understanding innovation
how did you come to this topic
well the evolution of everything came
out in 2015 and i've since written
another book um called
uh how innovation works
and i was already grappling with
innovation in the rational optimist in
2010 so these three books are in a sense
a trilogy
of attempts to tackle the subject of
innovation
first of all
how it delivers increasing human living
standards in the rational optimist
second how it's essentially an
evolutionary bottom-up process
we make the creationist mistake of
thinking that
we're in
charge of what happens in the world
somebody's in charge somebody's
responsible quite often that's not the
case quite often things come from the
bottom of society upwards not the top of
society down
and we find that hard to imagine and
then my third book how innovation works
is literally an attempt to create a
conversation about what innovation is
and where it comes from why it happens
to us and not to
other creatures and um
uh how to make it happen when we when we
need it it's it's a incredibly central
process to
human society but it's surprisingly
mysterious
why does that conversation matter why
why do we need to be talking about that
i think the pandemic reminds us why we
need to be talking about uh innovation
because had we done a better job of
innovating platforms for developing
vaccines
or
new diagnostic point-of-care handheld
devices for detecting viruses
before 2020
then we would have been in a much better
position to cope with
the coveted 19 crisis
um
in other words
in a world where we think we've had
incessant and
ubiquitous innovation when you look
around actually we have now nearly
enough
i write in my book about
two rather remarkable women who
developed a whooping cough vaccine from
a standing start mostly in their spare
time in four years in the 1930s and it
worked extremely well
whereas that would be quite good going
today
nearly a century later and that shows
that far from living in a time of
incessant innovation um we aren't we've
discovered incredible things about
genomics dna etc in the intervening
years and yet it hasn't managed to speed
up our rate of developing vaccines
that's rather a rebuke i think to our
civilization that we haven't done a
better job of that there is something
called the coalition for epidemic
preparedness innovation set up by the
gates foundation and the welcome trust
in 2017 which is tackling exactly this
problem it should have been set up 10 20
years earlier it should have been set up
by the world health organization etc so
i see the lack of innovation
in society is a relatively urgent um
issue that needs tackling
so it's not just that
things are
moving forward in an unplanned evolution
it's more that things aren't moving
forward at a good enough pace at all is
that what you're saying
yes i i do
make the case that a lot of this a lot
of innovation is unplanned a lot of it
is unpredictable
but there is no doubt that if you
uh
want
to that you can slow it down in certain
areas you can get in its way
so i think it's not a question of
speeding it up by throwing resources at
it so much as slowing it down by
throwing obstacles in its way if you
case if you take the case of medical
devices it takes
14 40 and 70 months to get
licensing approval for a new medical
device
in most western countries that's an
enormous investment of time and
therefore of money for an entrepreneur
and it results in entrepreneurs going
off and inventing video games instead
which are
basically permissionless there's nothing
there's no regulator there's nothing to
stop you inventing a
video game you don't have to sit and
wait for
bureaucrats to decide whether it's safe
um you don't have to spend a fortune on
your application
as peter thiel has pointed out we we
have undoubtedly
with our regulatory
governmental system diverted the efforts
of entrepreneurs
from
uh some useful things into some
relatively less useful things the way he
put it rather flamboyantly is we wanted
flying cars and we got 140 characters
what does an innovative state look like
what are the policies that you want to
see enacted to create more
i think what
an innovative state would look like is
one which cleared the obstacles out of
the ways of way of innovators and
entrepreneurs
created the conditions of freedom
freedom of decision making one of the
ways to do that is to speed up
government's decision making um we are
it's extraordinary how often
i came across examples of where the
government didn't actually say no to
something but it took such a long time
to say yes
that it
uh
killed all enthusiasm for the project so
you know the blight resistant potato
that doesn't need spraying 15 times in a
season that developed by the
bio company was it basf basf i think uh
in germany
um
went through
a process of such labyrinthine
um kafka-esque complexity you know at
one point they had
a court case saying
yes the government
was right to say it was safe
but
the government the eu was then taken to
court by something else saying yeah for
sure you can say it's safe but you've
got to rely on a different argument from
the one you used because that one's out
of date
we don't we're not disagreeing with the
fact that it's safe but we want you to
to think of some some other way of
saying it and that caused another two
two years delay by the time eventually
they got approval the company had lost
interest packed up its entire biotech
agricultural biotech team and packed it
off to america and said we're not
interested
we're giving up on europe that's the
kind of thing that's been happening and
it doesn't tend to get reported and it's
it's it it's a worry to me and so we can
do a lot better you know in this country
now that we've left the european union
we can uh change the definition of gmos
to exclude gene edited products like
almost the entire rest of the world is
doing
we can
simplify the procedures for approving or
disapproving of technologies
we can create
standards to help innovators get going
that's another way you know i write in
the book about the innovation of of
container shipping
that was really effectively the the
creation of a standard sized container
to go on ships and lorries
um
there are all sorts of imaginative ways
we could do that but it should be
focused on the the needs of the
entrepreneur and business
rather than
stimulating research at the academic end
in universities we do a lot of that
already it's very important it needs
doing but it's not it's not the limiting
step in my view
stories of um
individual innovators like james dyson
or elon musk are they
useful heroes or are they dangerous
myths
i on the whole don't believe in the in
the great man theory of history i think
napoleon was a product of the french
revolution as much as he was a cause of
the napoleonic wars in other words had
he not existed some other strong man
would have been thrown up by it this was
the argument that um was tackled at
length by tolstoy
uh um there are exceptions to that
individuals can
bend history to their will from time to
time
but i think one of the areas where we've
made a mistake
is in deifying
innovators and inventors and
entrepreneurs
eureka moments occurring to brilliant
individuals who happen to be extra
special creative types
is a myth in various ways a it's not
true there are lots people help them
and there are lots of people who
followed them and made it possible um
b it was much more of a collective uh
enterprise and c it tends to send the
message to people that don't apply to be
an innovator
unless you happen to be someone with
this special juice inside you called
creativity
and i think that's a myth i think if you
look at what edison did or bezos did
jeff bezos the amazon founder it was
hard work
trial and error
failure lots of it
bouncing back from failure change of
direction serendipity bit of luck a lot
of conversation with other people a lot
of collaboration well anyone can do
those things so i'm keen to to
demythologize uh innovators and i think
we're still putting them on a pedestal
too much and i would i would give elon
musk as an example of that some of elon
musk's achievements are remarkable and
great
others such as his suggestion that we
should
uh do intercity travel at 700 mph in
vacuum tubes
uh on struts above the ground and this
would be cheaper than either aeroplanes
or trains
it's just idiotic
um
so we should say so
is your view of innovation
a positive one
you know will we be able to save the
world if that's the case
i think there is no doubt that
innovation has been a force for good in
the last few centuries
you can put nuclear weapons on the table
and i can put
antibiotics on the table i'm pretty sure
my heap would be bigger than yours by
the end of the game
um
uh and one of the reasons for that is
because inventing nasty bad things
uh isn't going to catch on as well
people don't want nasty bad things as
much some do crooks do but they're
working in secret they're not able to
share their ideas they don't get as much
money etc so on the whole
goodwill trump bad in the race to
innovate
i think there's every reason to think
that will continue
i'm seeing innovations all the time
there's a there's a new
idea using bacteria to fix nitrogen on
crops which means we don't need to make
synthetic fertilizer
that's out there in the last couple of
years crispr the gene editing technology
some of the things that are being done
with ai to um
uh
enable
the diagnosis of cancers much earlier
and much more accurately you know that
we're going to live through some pretty
wonderful innovations in the next few
decades and it's the only way we're
going to solve some of our problems i
mean if we're really serious about
solving the problem of carbon dioxide
emissions we're only going to do it
through innovation we're not going to do
it through rolling out existing
technologies they're not good enough
they're not strong enough they're not
cheap enough we're going to have to
invent carbon capture and storage or
better forms of nuclear power or some
other form of energy generation
who are your heroes who who
who stands out for you who do you keep
coming back to in your head
well having said that i don't believe in
heroes on the whole uh it would be a bit
hypocritical for me to single out uh
innovators but
i i do think thomas edison is a
remarkable figure because he spotted
that innovation is a
is a product that you can make in a
factory
uh and he said about it in just the
right way not
not trying to be too clever just trying
to try hard
and
do a lot of trial and error and i would
put jeff bezos in a similar
category as someone who
has created
an enormous benefit to the world in the
form of online retail
he's you know he's
he's broken a few eggs to make his
omelette if you like along the way um
but he has done so uh with great
single-mindedness and achievement
but actually i'm going to duck the
question a little bit about my heroes by
mentioning a heroic
innovation itself
and the guy who did it who is not a
household name
although i'm trying to make him one
and that is the insecticide treated bed
net
which has completely reversed the trend
in malaria deaths in the world until
2003 they were increasing since then
they've been rapidly decreasing that was
the year the gates foundation started
rolling out this technology it's a very
simple low-tech low-cost solution it's
been twice as effective as every other
measure put together to try and
solve malaria and it came about because
of
an experiment done in burkina faso in
1983
by a bunch of french scientists uh
working with one vietnamese colleague
and some burkina fason colleagues
which just did an experiment to find out
if adding insecticide to a mosquito net
helped uh particularly if the mosquito
net was already torn and the answer was
it helped enormously it was a huge
huge deterrent to um
mosquitoes and quite safe and so uh
frederick dariot who did that experiment
and it was never properly published i
managed to track down the original
mimeograph report of it
i managed to contact him in retirement
and i you know asked him how he came to
do it and
what the impact was etc and my french
isn't very good and he's his english was
non-existent
that's the kind of guy that i think
should be my hero in the world of
innovation
what's next for you after the trilogy
what's to follow
i will write another book at some point
um
it it at the moment it seems to take me
about five years to get around to
publishing another book so don't hold
your breath
[Music]
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the institute of art
and ideas
at iai tv